ongoing and widespread flooding in
eastern australia where people have lost
lives and livelihoods to the rising
water
human-caused climate change is
increasing the risk of this kind of
event
now a dire warning from the un's
intergovernmental panel on climate
change that over 3 billion people nearly
half the planet's population are living
in harm's way because of global warming
i've seen many scientific reports in my
time but nothing like this
today's ipcc report is an atlas of human
suffering
and the damning indictment of failed
climate leadership
with fact upon fact this report reveals
how people on the planet are getting
clobbered by climate change
as wildfires burn in argentina the un
predicts unavoidable and irreversible
impacts on humans animals and the
ecosystems they rely on
even if temperature rises are limited to
a best case scenario
and as recent flooding in the west
midlands shows this is not a problem
limited to far away places
the hard bit is working out how to adapt
to the changes that are already here and
the ones that are predicted to come in
this country for example that might mean
better land management it might mean
more flood defenses or even moving some
communities away from the water
altogether
whatever the solution it's going to be
expensive and the longer we wait the
more expensive it's going to get
still the report warns as climate change
drives food and water scarcity and even
conflict
some people and places are already being
pushed beyond their ability to adapt no
matter what is spent in the future
i think it's an incredibly uh stark
warning it's a grim warning and
you know i would argue this is another
code red for humanity and what this
report says to us is that the impact on
lives and livelihoods and nature are far
worse than were originally anticipated
and not only that but those who are
affected the most disproportionately are
those who are most uh vulnerable
those vulnerable communities need more
help and quickly from rich nations
everywhere at the same time as global
efforts to reduce carbon emissions are
also stepped up
a huge challenge that the world we are
told must rise to
hannah thomas peter sky news